buenos días más bien buenos muy
calurosos días porque la situación de
hoy hace un calor terrible
beirut pues se ha levantado esta mañana
triste triste y vacía con las calles
desiertas sin tráfico con todos los
comercios establecimientos oficinas del
gobierno restaurants y bancos cerrando
sus puertas al público porque como
decías hoy se ha declarado día de luto
nacional en los hogares de los libaneses
se viven sentimientos encontrados de ira
de indignación pero también de
simplemente asumir la situación porque
realmente en estos momentos el líbano
está con una situación tan compleja con
una terrible crisis económica social y
política que da muy poco margen a la
esperanza esta tarde hay manifestaciones
y se espera que sean muchos los
libaneses que acudan a todas estas
marchas que se van a celebrar de forma
simultánea en diferentes puntos de la
ciudad pero no se sabe cuánta gente va a
poder acudir o cuánta gente
se va a quedar en sus casas